hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute in meinem basic
video euch eine leckere schokoladencreme
vorstellen und zwar könnt ihr die gräben
benutzen entweder als topping für
cupcakes oder auch als füllung für zum
beispiel eine torte und die creme
besteht aus zwei zutaten oder 3 und zwar
bis hier 300 gramm sahne 200 gramm
schokolade und ich brauche etwas
sonderbar später zum festigen
ich habe jetzt hier zarter schokolade
aber ihr können zum beispiel auch weiße
schokolade nehmen vollmilch schokolade
oder eben eine andere schwarze herren
schokolade zum beispiel oder auch
schokolade mit geschmack so was wie
yogurette oder irgendetwas anderes mit
erfüllung
und ich gebe es zuerst die sahne in den
topf die muss nämlich erwärmt werden
also einmal kurz aufkochen lassen
wenn dieser dann auf gekochtes toll ich
den herd aus und gibt die schokolade mit
rein
und während dem rühren kann die sich
jetzt schön auflösen
jetzt fühle ich die schoko sahne um die
muss nämlich jetzt erst wieder komplett
kalt werden
ihr könnt so was gern auch schon einen
tag vorher machen und dann im
kühlschrank kalt werden lassen oder ihr
lasst sie eben jetzt für mindestens zwei
stunden im kühlschrank also die muss
einfach wieder kühlschranktemperatur
annehmen und dann können wir sie später
aufschlagen
die schokoladen sahne ist jetzt richtig
schön kalt und damit ich sie jetzt auf
cupcakes aufspritzen kann muss ich jetzt
erst noch aufschlagen und das könnt ihr
jetzt ganz einfach mit einem schneebesen
einem handrührgerät machen und wenn ihr
möchtet gebt mir da etwas sein apartment
dazu dann wird nämlich die sahne später
auch standfest
jetzt könnt ihr diese fertige creme zum
beispiel auf capex spritzen oder auch
einen transporten füllung benutzen
die cupcakes sind so direktes sei wir
bereit die creme hat nämlich die
optimale temperatur
wir können sie aber auch ganz gerne
nochmal im kühlschrank lagern und wenn
ich das rezept gefallen hat freue ich
mich wenn ihr das nach macht und besucht
meinem blog auf sullivans blog.de da
stehen noch mal die genauen
mengenangaben bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss